hey chimichangas is Charlie so this is
going to be my Deadpool video Ryan
Reynolds and the studio confirmed some
things about the movies this past
weekend so we have a lot to talk about
like we have an official synopsis now
here's what it says
Deadpool tells the origin story of
former Special Forces operative turned
mercenary Wade Wilson who after being
subjected to a rogue experiment that
leaves him with accelerated healing
powers adopts the alter-ego Deadpool
armed with his new abilities in a dark
twisted sense of humor
Deadpool hunts down the man who nearly
destroyed his life so we have a lot of
things from Weapon X that we've seen in
the x-men film so far that they're going
to weave into this and I think you know
some suggestions as to who the main
villains going to be what I think is is
that they'll use dr. Killebrew and Ajax
as the villains of the movie or at least
dr. Killebrew they haven't confirmed any
official villains yet they've only
really announced like a couple of the
characters including Morena Baccarin
who's playing copycat if you weren't
already excited about Ryan Reynolds
coming back in a new Deadpool origin
story then get pumped for Morena
Baccarin kicking some major ass
seriously she's like the queen of the
comic book genre right now she's on the
flash as the Gideon computer she's on
Gotham as Leslie Thompkins and now she's
in the x-men universe as copycat don't
worry I'm gonna do a whole separate
video about her eventually just because
she's a really interesting character in
Morena Baccarin is awesome they've
already confirmed the Deadpool movie is
a spinoff from the x-men films the first
class films that they've been doing the
last couple of years the timeline is a
little wonky because they had that
post-credit scene in Days of Future past
so here's my general explainer as to
like how this Deadpool movie fits in
with the other x-men films that are
happening including apocalypse just
careful for spoilers from Days of Future
past I'm assuming you've all seen it by
now but just I'll give you a second okay
here we go so forget about the teaser at
the end of that when they flash forward
to the future with Wolverine and Patrick
Stewart just put that out of your mind
they're not changing that that still
happens but because x-men apocalypse
takes place in the 80s right after Days
of Future past the Deadpool movie is
probably gonna take place around then
too Deadpool's origin story is all about
Weapon X and at the end of Days of
Future Passed if you remember William
Stryker dredged Wolverine up from the
bottom of the river
well really it was mystique masquerading
as William Stryker the teaser was is
that William Stryker was going to in
ducked him into the Weapon X program
Wolverine came before Deadpool in the
Weapon X program the problem is is that
you know because mystique changed the
timeline she saved Wolverine pretending
to be William Stryker there's a lot of
questions as to like how he's going to
get his adamantium because he does
eventually get it just assume that
Weapon X still exists and at some point
Wolverine does get his adamantium from
them the reason I don't think that
they're going to change that even though
they changed the timeline a little bit
is because Deadpool got his healing
factor from Wolverine inside the Weapon
X program so Weapon X has to get their
hands on Wolverines healing factor in
the comics Weapon X gives Wolverine his
adamantium during the 80s so it fits in
the timeline with Days of Future past
and apocalypse what I think is going to
happen is is that we'll have the events
of apocalypse and then the Deadpool
movie will take place in the timeline
right after that don't ask me how full
Vareen 3 is supposed to fit into this I
think that will also occur in the
timeline after the the Deadpool movie
and apocalypse because we don't know
anything about that story yet justjust
don't worry about it here's a quick
explainer for Deadpool's back story in
the comics like how he got started with
Weapon X how he got his powers so funny
story Rob Liefeld is Deadpool's crater
in the comics he created in like the
early 90s there's there's a really funny
story like a funny Rob Liefeld story
behind it Rob Liefeld came up with the
idea send it to the artist and the
artist said this is Deathstroke dude
seriously this is totally Deathstroke
from the DC Comics so they changed the
design just like a little bit and they
gave him the name Wade Wilson as a spin
as like an inside joke on Slade Wilson
aka Deathstroke comic-book history is
littered with characters that are riffs
of other pre-existing characters so this
is nothing new the really funny thing is
is that Rob Liefeld actually wrote on
the new 52 Deathstroke title whenever DC
Comics was doing that the new 52 stuff
back in 2012 he quit that title like in
the middle of the run he's like I can't
take it anymore this is crazy there were
a lot of logistical editorial problems
with a DC news 52 run that's like a
whole other story but I just think it's
funny that Rob Liefeld kind of borrowed
quote-unquote borrowed the Deathstroke
character to create Deadpool and then
quit a Deathstroke title he was writing
later the universe works in mysterious
ways
we don't know a whole lot about Wayne
Wilson's childhood other than
he had some undiagnosed mental problems
he was very aloof but eventually he
became a mercenary during his adventures
he fell in love with a woman named
Vanessa Carlysle who had not become
copycat yet she's copycat in the comics
she has this really awesome power it's a
lot like Mystique's she can shape-shift
but it goes down to the genetic level so
she can mimic other people's powers in a
way that mystique cannot like I said I'm
totally gonna do another bonus video for
her just because she's really
interesting it in Morena Baccarin is
amazing eventually he learned he had
cancer broke ties with Vanessa Carlysle
and joined the Weapon X program Weapon X
and Department Cait grew out of the
original Captain America super soldier
program they're like a dark twisted
future version of the super soldier
program they got Wilson to join the
program by saying they could fix his
cancer they gave him Wolverines healing
factor that fixed the cancer the problem
is is that it did not fix his underlying
mental instability and in a very evil
Genie type situation be careful what you
wish for type stuff as a result of the
healing factor he can't take drugs to
balance himself out and they can't
physically alter his brain to try and
fix it any changes they try to make to
it chemical or biological just his body
just burns off immediately so he is
stuck crazy
there was a time later in the comics
when he lost his healing factor but it
still didn't fix his brain so it's like
the character is always gonna be crazy
so while this is all going on in the
comics he's still Wade Wilson he hasn't
become Deadpool yet but he does have the
healing factor he starts going on
missions with Weapon X ends up killing
one of his teammates they boot him out
of the program and send him to a
facility where they send washouts that
is where he runs into dr. kill brew and
his assistant Ajax two very very evil
people why is in the facility they
perform all kinds of crazy experiments
on him in the other washouts he does end
up meeting and falling in love with the
cosmic entity death starts trying to
kill himself over and over so he can
join her which is kind of crazy and
funny at the same time cut to later he
pisses off Ajax the assistant so much
that Ajax messes up Wilson's friend in
the program so bad that Wilson is forced
to kill him out of mercy
Ajax rips Wilson's heart out of his
chest and leaves him for dead just like
dumps the body his healing factor
regrows him a heart but it doesn't fix
all the scars on his body so he starts
looking more like the Deadpool that you
see today without the
masks on while he was in the facility
being tested on all the other test
subjects developed a Deadpool to bet on
who would survive the longest like who
would go the longest without dying from
the experiments deadpool takes that name
and vows revenge on ajax in kill brew so
that's where you get the deadpool name
that's where it came from because this
movie is telling kind of the origin
story of deadpool i think that we're
gonna see a version of that play out on
screen though the probably make some
minor changes i'm not expecting to see
the cosmic entity death i know everyone
kind of wants to see death in the Marvel
Universe eventually but technically this
is an x-men film so who knows what
they're gonna do with that they might
just substitute Vanessa Carlysle for
death maybe Marvel can make that happen
like death can take Vanessa Carlysle
face here's my big question for you guys
which other big Deadpool characters do
you want to see in this movie and do you
think that they're gonna put death in
the movie too Fox has not done a shower
movie they haven't done like a
space-based x-men universe movie yet so
they're like three steps away from doing
cosmic entities like I said my next
Deadpool bonus video is going to be a
map Morena Baccarin copycat character be
sure to subscribe to get that
is there any other like special Deadpool
videos you guys want me to do let me
know but I'll try and post that sometime
next week there's like a whole bunch of
awesome stuff happening in the next
couple of days that I need to get out
here's a quick update on my video
schedule for like the next day or two
just because there's like three or four
videos I'm trying to get out so they
just confirm Hawkgirl for the arrow
flash spinoff so I'm gonna do a video
for that before flash tomorrow I also
have the Walking Dead Q&A don't worry
I'm giving away two gift certificates
and that and I have a special
crunchyroll giveaway that I'm going to
do so I'll try and drop that all
tomorrow morning or at least all that
stuff by Wednesday morning you guys have
no idea how excited I get one like all
this awesome news just dumps it once all
at the same time while you guys wait for
that in kit in case you haven't seen it
yet you can click here for my top 5
Deadpool stories from the comics and you
can click here for my Walking Dead
finale video from last night thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five and go get some change on guys
you